citizens of the reject Nation welcome to another
action spectacular the two Jack disc guys
doing reactions in the game going Gregor and
watch dread Greg has seen it as a child I
saw it as a child I remember little to nothing
but it being a cinematic Masterpiece that's
all you need to remember it was designed for
four-year-olds so it's been like 31 years
I think I missed an entire comic book series
because there's two of them I've not seen
either I knew I hadn't seen the second one
I've never seen this I haven't seen the second
one so we'll do a first time watching for
the Carl Urban one I love sitting on this
side I feel like it's stretching out this
side of my neck a little more trash I very
very much love the comic book uh one of my
buddies jock has brought the comic book back
to life it is a very beautiful book it is
very historically like loved it's one of those
cult Comics that has really endured the test
of time so we're gonna dive in and uh we're
gonna see how it goes are you excited you
didn't say any of the stuff nope didn't and
remember hit that like hit that notification
intro going to
that's true that's true but I'm gonna go just
from the bottom here remember to hit that
notification Bell hit that like button so
you know that you want to see dread too which
is really just dread reboot and leave a comment
below especially with action movies you want
us to watch so let us know if there's anything
you're like I bet these guys haven't seen
black leave a comment below and which dread
do you like more this one or the new one with
uh Joel Ken Carl Urban and all of his growly
glory
I suppose though we don't have a patreon anymore
we're out of patrons they're all dead and
if you want to watch this completely with
us from front to back start to finish and
see me and Greg's resting faces become a patron
and be super sexy over there with us as we
dive into dread that intro is going to be
called Coy's failed intro
[Music] oh I
missed this logo I always thought that looked
like Arnold Schwarzenegger like they yeah
the night in the face of them
so bad now I'm not gonna unsee it because
he's so chiseled and he's got the big cheekbones
and like that I see it you love Comics I love
these things they make yeah look at this reference
in the comics more than the average comic
movie
this is fantastic
is this suggesting we're stepping into a comic
book it feels like it we're going into the
between the panels in the third millennium
the world changed climate Nations all were
in upheaval yes transformed into a poisonous
scorched desert known as the cursed Earth
millions of people crowded into a few mega
cities bands of Street Savages created violence
the justice system could not control law as
we know it collapsed a society ruled by a
new Elite Force they were the police jury
and executioner all in one they were the judges
whose voice is that it's the butt to butt
guy from Requiem for a Dream for sure right
all right I didn't say it because it's on
YouTube I want to demonetize but that's the
scene that's okay thought ahead
ah actual models
it sounds like Dune Vibes Diane Lane's in
this that's right I remember that shocking
Aspen prison shuttle docked what he's the
first character you see I would never have
guessed six-month sentence Aspen prison served
welcome back citizen your living assignment
is why block Heavenly Haven red quad ah he's
returning to society [Music] uh don't you
miss when future movies used to do this stuff
now they're like what's a realistic future
look at that like overly done yeah this is
just cool stacks on Stacks also some Fifth
Element Vibes one of us will reference Blade
Runner eventually and we'll get there wait
till a raining shot man [Music]
Statue of Liberty is just right there just
chilling this is built around it
oh my God this is just LA on the weekend recycled
food
ill be kind and peaceful to each other eat
recycled food ew
what's his name Dexter Morgan's Dad yeah James
something James yeah
maybe I should [Music] go there
block war block war it's a war on their block
[Music] uh it's just like a free-for-all of
death because it doesn't look like they're
specifically attacking anyone they were just
doing their own thing judges
it's a pretty Slumber shot It's gotta be him
[Music] foreign practical effects here yeah
I really like it yeah yeah through the fire
[Music]
[Music] [Laughter] yes come and get us
he's crazy
the effect of legal range is 200 meters you're
safe you can still be shot so it hurt waiting
for backup it's here
I'm lost
[Music] got how cool that gun was practical
Smooth Criminal foreign
[Music] [Laughter] [Music]
[Music]
that's an official move it must be all right
double whammy code 457 resisting arrest 20
years
thank you and code 3613 the first degree murder
mystery church so much judging let me guess
life
death death yeah this movie's perfect did
they just kill Robert Schneider off camera
he was our Island thanks so damn it oh that
was Diane Lane it's good for the environment
and okay for you please make your selection
insert your credit in the slot oh I see his
voice
go by e you are in the way of the circle Droid
what boy am I glad to see you hopeful sabotage
of a public Droid that's six months citizen
let's see a unicorn oh my God Church you are
unreasonable he was trying to live and survive
five years five years
[Music]
who is this guy die legally
comedy I can't tell if it's like a commentary
on blob like the Gilded Eagle on his shoulder
like what is this okay it's up it's like intentionally
funny so much
you may start at East Joseph face reveal the
Mandalorian oh my God it's Sylvester Stallone
I never would have known
you really remember what you taught me sir
you were my finest student history starting
tomorrow you're going to spend two days a
week at the Academy not killing people killing
student Achilles dudes it's about Judge Dread
learning not to kill Snape goes back to school
unfair incarceration all the time I don't
cross anything
I'm a ghost and we're both prisoners here
oh it was just very familiar but but can't
play some Our Mysterious benefactor has sent
you a package deactivate Shield auto guns
only oil guns reactivated Warden Miller said
Lord and Miller Lord and Miller it's a premonition
what is that that's an ancient puzzle that
contains the meaning of life why would you
have your Shields down around this guy why
would you scan the side of your thumb instead
of the front of it what is the meaning of
life foreign
that's the meaning of life [Applause] [Music]
voice not recognized under the throat no
security override and unlocked Stormtroopers
get in there you'll miss he's not in this
tiny space he must not be oh there it is
that every judge must take outside these City
walls and there spend your last remaining
days taking law to the Lawless that's a retirement
dying alone outside that's winning you made
it sound like our lives are practically over
you haven't gotten used to the isolation the
Curry's lit loneliness no one is supposed
to be alone all the time haven't you ever
had a friend it's cold as ice
once I rested him he broke the law Jay what
10 years
I judged him he is hilarious in this movie
is he aware I don't know he's so funny what
is the genre he's the best park it's so good
so funny oh it's a wide boy who's that Stormtrooper
focused on that for a reason one of them yes
[Music]
even altarped up he could still aim that well
impressive it is impressive I don't know why
he took off his dog tags though he was wearing
them in the prison they seemed important to
him at the time now it's played now it's Blade
Runner Blade Runner bizarre
good casting though see this guy looks very
drawn he looks like a comic character yeah
it's a good call like The Duality between
him and Stallone both looking it was inevitable
20. hello this is antiques I thought they
destroyed all these ABC Warriors during the
last war ABC Warriors hey wait a second don't
touch it that's programmed to only recognize
a judge's hand you touch that it will take
your arm off I must be a church why is that
Kellen but try to kill everyone come on are
there giant Mech robots in this you know cool
it's been 31 years if you don't remember that
he's pretty cool you have an Iron Giant coming
in oh now he's programmed too it's all six
he just hotwired a robot we're allowed to
happen if they don't work oh cool yes
[Music]
I don't care what Aaron says that looks awesome
that is so badass [Music]
no [Music]
[Music] I wonder if he was framed nope that
seems like what's up he was judged ball man
was just like [__] this well he talked
[__] about him out judge Hershey call
control for an H web you're gonna tell me
this is your fourth violation bar breath you
are minutes how do you please not guilty I
knew you'd say that wait a second what are
you doing grenade grenade no way
first violation to so forth I blow it up Superman
is so extreme I just blew up his card that's
so much destruction of property Madrid you're
under arrest what's the charge abusing the
law this man is clearly innocent he just blew
up a car easiest cop to frame ever in front
of Rick ruin of course you can frame this
guy there's a blown up Lamborghini fights
everything is the worst defense I judged him
have you selected someone to defend you judge
Hershey got the academy she was at the top
of her class in interpretation of Law and
I trust her the facts will come out at the
trombone I'll personally make sure of that
oh when the guy had the gun taken out there
that dude's face was in the uh no the it was
the oh yeah the yeah the guy killed the journalist
yeah yeah it was a hit we know that the uniform
of a judge can be counterfeit and that the
badge can be duplicated and since neither
the video nor the audio in this presentation
can identify the accused my objection to this
video being allowed as evidence in this case
is no one aware that a former judge turned
criminals maybe it's a coincidence Maybe should
we alert them a lot of people died as a result
of the DNA coding on those bullets the DNA
is a perfect match for judge Joseph dress
what how do you steal someone's DNA how could
I have been so wrong correct both of them
homicidal I dread this the day I have long
dread oh wait he just said both of them are
homicidal He's the bad guy yeah it's his brother
it's his brother yeah he just said it brother
wouldn't be a perfect match surprised they
just reveal all that [__] for you how's
the brother a perfect match though that's
not a DNA works there is a way out chief justice
A Long Walk that's a death sentence judge
Griffin you're a retirement grants you the
power to save dread's life I know this guy's
a good guy but he comes across so evil he's
evil I don't know man tribunal finds Joseph
dread guilty that's chalk did they say the
DNA match was dread or Joseph dread did they
find Joseph dread guilty okay that's not how
DNA works it has long been our custom to carry
out the last order of a retiring senior judge
and so I stepped down way to go dread just
made everything worse now the big evil guy's
gonna be the big bad come on as it is written
Justice Griffin this trial has been a farce
I demand an appeal you will accept the Court's
decision is very believable in Smith acting
let us armor be taken from him and all his
scarf of Justice [Music]
forever I thought they wanted this to be the
first movie oh yeah they're like stripping
from being judged act too [Laughter] show
a bunch of comic frames let him take the law
he served so well to those who have it not
so now he's gotta go walk into Exile because
he was a judge what a weird system because
it was his trade the last order was to keep
him alive thank you
what a boring way to live He's gotta go fight
a sand worm
oh my goodness cool visual they're constrained
by the time but the visuals are really cool
like well production designed and stuff definitely
a lot of striking like dystopian sci-fi imagery
I can't believe you were ever a baby and the
baby
uh the one guy he judged his brother was also
his friend I'd assume that's who he was talking
about we were supposed to meet someplace safe
oh
you mess with him you mess with me the robot
makes the whole movie for me Hammond had to
be silenced he found out about Janus but I
could have used red he worships the law yeah
let me see what it's like to freeze his ass
off in Aspen let him see what it's like to
be me
there's a lot of work to be done I like the
exposed cables on that it's really cool yeah
you want chaos I beginning yeah in the beginning
it's really unhinged I don't know what he's
aiming for exactly but all right you know
he's uh the blank we got two bad guys stuff
I'm uh mustache twirl with throwing stuff
this is legit looks like an episode of Mandalorian
like this could pass for a Disney pleasure
that's great
he broke out of that easily oh dread you looking
out
he punches very hard oh no [Music] oh no
[Music] oh my God if I oppressive his nostrils
are they consume
what are they hoping for I think feed him
I said I'm gonna get a city boy oh yeah you're
probably right he looks familiar that actor
too at the cut face awake neat good we're
running out of stickers oh my God it's becoming
a Rob Zombie movie they played White Zombie
earlier
oh Lord you have flashed us indeed damn the
design of this one guy is really hard to take
your eyes off yeah he's cool excuse me we're
not together the Practical in his chest is
so cool it's disturbing as hell
that come with a four cancer nice [Music]
ouch ouch oof Hallelujah can it be that from
the city of the Fallen
and we really don't do it it sounds like we
have a believer cut him down maybe the law
doesn't make mistakes but I'm free you're
toast actually your toast your new friends
they're cannibals laughs fresh foreign [Music]
[Music]
oh [Music] my goodness let's see if he just
kills these guys guilty corrupt cops all right
[Music] it's like a digital Rambo gun they
didn't do anything wrong just doing the job
like he would yeah they're dead though guilty
[Music]
Max von Saito from the outside Joseph together
again I walked 300 miles I found you my son
what did not expect it did not expect it
they brought him back to kill him with Frankenstein
he was around for like a second at a scene
of reunion [Music]
illegal use of city electricity
do you say that
whoa cool that's a great shot
it's full of anomalies really clever ones
too somebody must have used the CGI terminal
in a scan quad to make this 20 years ago whoa
CGI terminal it's real it's the baby
is he made in the lab is the guy a clone so
he has the same DNA that would make more sense
not a brother wait is dreaded which one's
the Clone are they both alone four decades
ago DNA samples were taken from the original
castle one was chosen mine we altered it to
enhance this quality yes I created you it
is Blade Runner is that why he behaves like
such a crazy Soldier because he's not a person
whose programs
in that experiment but something went wrong
genetically mutated to the perfect criminal
oh that it wasn't the one that got Justice
and for his crimes you judged him he was his
brother he didn't realize his brother was
his brother
he put that together remarkably fast that
other guy was asking him [Music]
I feel like we're watching what should have
been a part two oh 100 like no introduction
of the judges no introduction of these countries
like the the brother Discovery sequel is 100
a second movie the fall of the city didn't
happen for us [Music] hiding in the dumps
that's such cool character design there is
a solution project James this Council tried
to play God once before this whole sailed
Slaughter of Judges continues there won't
be a council it's kind of like a Nazi a little
bit of Desperate Times fascist regime
all right you ready kid
no it's your brain there's a maniac loose
in this city there's one out here too
this did me I wouldn't be here in the first
place and I'm gonna stay here until I'm caught
or until you apologize the law can't apologize
[Music] you're not the law anymore now apologize
I think I deserve that I've never apologized
is it a comedy he's so funny [Music]
not smart
it's the first time it was a tad intense yeah
that was a moment yeah I'm alive
[Laughter] great that's so funny oh I could
see how Schneider started a career from this
I just really he's actually really sorry
I'm lost is this the bathroom why are you
taking off his clothes
time for this [Laughter] that was such good
delivery
that was so funny
[Laughter] like wasn't sarcastic at all it's
like no judgment or something [Music]
Brothers clones
this is a
surprisingly great dude
they like work really well together good job
casting director yeah [Music]
how are they staying on it [Music]
[Music] wow what did come first this or Fifth
Element there's a lot of crossover yeah
[Music]
Oh I thought he shot his own the car I think
they hit the edge of the thing and it launched
back
well timed
I love how he's just killing other innocent
literally people that did his job I know he's
like I am the law but kill the law for doing
the law there also is co-workers like he knows
these people happy birthday
[Music] murder him's ready
that's a bad guy you just killed I my mind
says you guys had lunch together before
you know the truth who are you dread said
that shut up we're dying out there 108 judges
in 48 hours he killed 20 of them we know they're
not all judges there's just something below
that Central take this DNA sample wasn't part
of our plan
jeez the next batch of Genius judges are not
gonna be the puppets that you want they're
gonna be my brothers and sisters and mine
to control
wait what a dumbass in front of that I'm gonna
pull out this little gun in front of this
Iron Giant murder machine this is a really
long 90 minutes oddly for how much action
for how much fun dialogue we've laughed a
lot very long 90 but I still feel the run
time and it's it's less than like an animated
film like how foreign
[Music] oh no they just kill Rob Schneider
we thought it before
[Music] how does dread ever friends with this
guy he seems like he's just so much yes the
worst yeah he's like Mr long until you evolve
into this like what send in the Clones
what are we about to see send in the Clones
done this is just a bunch of hymns there's
no like process oh there's no okay never mind
they're cooking I thought it was a bunch of
him just done cooked head off instead
[Music]
oh he's a hacker what that Rob Schneider's
a hacker oh oh okay
[Music] thank you [__] nicely done Central
I said first set of clothes the cloning process
is not finished Judge Rico the Clones will
be only 60 complete what are we gonna do it's
60 just gloop around yeah [Music] cat fight
[Applause]
[Music]
they behave like Monsters 100 [Music] not
like these two guys who are also close they
get empathy last come on
[Music] every every cat fight you gotta say
you gotta say [__] she just say judge
[__] I think she said judgment but I like
that better this is Judge [__] judge [__]
oh they were in the central Liberty the whole
time I did not realize that I'm the only one
Blade Runner right now freedom [Music] Liberty
conscious thought in the brain of Liberty
way to go drug dread
a little rounds exhausted
smart
[Music] then he fell on 12 innocent people
adding to his murder rate of five an hour
we have to reconstitute the council we'd like
you to consider the first position of Chief
Justice oh that's great he gets all the credit
I taught him everything he knows dread is
he just going back to work right now he's
good he's good
no she went for it the truth I'm probably
a much better kisser okay come on let's go
will you uh Queen by a cash machine
I feel emotions
he's just gonna pose yeah
oh I'm gonna just close my eyes here for a
minute I fall off the Liberty building again
I'll just post here
oh Jesus wow you did it that was I've seen
a comic movie I've never seen before these
are always fun wow oh God that was uh that
was a long 90 man I know I'm shocked that
a movie can be that short long I mean it's
not great it's not great but it is fun it's
fun but it is fun it is fun I'm really glad
I saw it I think in this context it is the
ideal way to watch it I don't think I would
have made it through without you no I don't
know if I would have just been like odd dread
like I don't know that that would have gotten
finished all right man well Sylvester Stallone
would you think of George I don't know if
he knew the movie or if we knew I I don't
know if Stallone made a drama and we all saw
it as a comedy or if the director like he
was so sincere in a lot of that delivers funny
like I don't know what do you think to this
day Stallone thinks this is like a drama ah
I'd be curious to know I know that people
don't like this movie I feel good about having
fun with it knowing it's not great yeah I
didn't it couldn't help but feel like it was
um I mean I love Stallone in it though I love
still owning it I just don't know if he knew
what it was he's the best part for all the
reasons you wouldn't say he's the best he's
so because he's so committed he's so sincere
he's so committed and I respect it because
I feel like he's gotta have some level like
does Stallone have awareness or is he like
Vin Diesel that's what I mean is this a casting
director going I'm very clever or is this
a cash director going like this is what the
movie needs you know what I mean yeah yeah
cause he's because he even worked really well
off Rob Schneider and the performance even
came more to life when Rob Schneider is like
the panicky finicky oh yeah and he's super
stoked he's saying awesome one-liners yeah
but he's even saying one-liners that are like
intentionally funny to bounce off 100 Rob
Schneider and I thought they they said that
was probably the most surprising part the
Buddy Duo between the two of them that I never
would have it's a felt it was really Charming
I wonder if people like it as much as us and
they're putting there's there's questionable
things where I'm like I wonder if that's a
thing that Coy and Greg like but others
because we're like this Duo really worked
for me I also love the Practical effects I
mean we said it a lot but I was so enamored
with the World building they really made a
cool set and like lived in it everywhere and
despite what you think about uh uh Rico Starship
Troopers despite what you think about Rico
uh this is like the 90s name I think it was
a commentary on the Rico laws of the time
oh was it yeah you know like Rico laws like
when you get arrested and like one of your
other known associates get arrested you can
charge the whole group with that crime yeah
I think it was a commentary on like what the
times were with Law and Order in the mid 90s
like the Rico laws got drafted around the
time like Tupac was killed so it was a big
commentary on like gang Warfare and then there
was also like the three strikes law that was
the same time that's because the opening was
about like the guy getting five years for
something ridiculous so I feel like it was
a commentary on like RICO law and the three
strikes maybe yeah or I'm thinking about it
because I felt like this movie wanted to be
a Paul verhoven film right it wanted to be
Paul who did like Robocop and Starship Troopers
which has a uh satirical awareness about it
and I think it wanted to be that but it got
condensing to make it a 90-minute action film
it still drags at times surprisingly what
I'd take out either it's not like scenes I
think you would need to add stuff in and make
stuff better I don't think it's about taking
make it better everything's about taking stuff
out I think it's about making things more
interesting sure and and instead of um you
know take because there was something about
once the loan's taken it's so serious that
it was funny because you say ridiculous [__]
and giving insane convictions yeah every time
they'd show me they'd be like look at his
eyes and the strings would swell that he'd
say like a line that would be like a Wanderer
from Mel Gibson and Lethal Weapon yeah it
didn't have it didn't have a the whole tone
didn't have awareness right um so Rob Schneider
was funny Stallone uh seemed this alone seemed
to I don't know I'm just gonna I'm gonna Edge
towards the loan I don't know I don't awareness
I'm gonna go 60 40. yeah I'm gonna I'm just
gonna give him the benefit of the death because
it was just working so but it's only working
uh uh like 30 years later right right now
or was it like back then people were like
he's funny you know that's a great question
did audiences see this movie then or are we
seeing it because we live in this meta era
yeah yeah yeah that's what that is a big question
mark um I don't know maybe the RICO thing
is actually because maybe the comics did yeah
I think I just saw the name Rico is listed
by one of the credits oh really yeah so maybe
maybe it's not as hideous I wanted to give
a credit oh yeah yeah it's just the guy's
name I'm like oh he's a commentary or the
name Rico hey uh yeah I like um I like the
guy who played he played John Gotti in a movie
I think the movie is called Gotti um no he
did not play John God in the Travolta movies
oh Travolta plays Gotti yes oh I thought he
was just in a movie named God I know he played
Dottie yeah oh two goddess hey it's Arnold
Arnold's on screen um yeah so John he played
Gotti in that uh but I I haven't seen that
gaudy movie I just I remember the cover now
is so and and it's not like there's any plan
to ever react to this guy that's awesome cheese
it was something to come but should we watch
demolition man because I hear it's great I
mean I've seen him I I remember Demolition
Man pretty well okay I just know there's a
Taco Bell in it yes that's all I know about
it because of the FBI I don't remember Demolition
Man I don't remember the Taco Bell there's
a whole thing where they opened a Blade Runner
Taco Bell I mean a Demolition Man Taco Bell
in the style of it and everybody was all excited
and I was like cool oh not ringing a bell
oh cool yeah I mean I just I mean I love the
two of them oh it's so Judge Dread and uh
practical the music the music was so good
if it was him it was great uh yeah we just
didn't take the time to look at the credits
look at the [__] difference in the scores
4.2 000 people gave it four and a half star
or like wild four and a half stars for four
point two thousand people but IMDb 5.6 I mean
it's fun I had a great time it's a fun movie
it's a group mute like this would not be fun
to just sit and watch the thing is the World
created I don't know how appreciated it was
back then yeah because even when you compare
it to Fifth Element The Fifth Element feels
more there's a lot of practical there's a
lot of practical uh it still has feels like
there's even more seeds yet but it just looks
better and the movie feels like those worlds
exist like I buy the mythology I buy the aliens
I buy the locations whereas like so good that
one's incredible that's such a good movie
great movie but that's a little bit more like
oh I get why this is here whereas this is
like that looks cool yes yes and I think like
we can appreciate it now because of what Cinema
has devolved into yeah because there's nothing
paid it was yeah so much CGI that we can watch
this and go this looks awesome how sad is
that we're like wow that's cool they built
a thing yeah like the bar shouldn't be just
have it be able to be touched and Max von
Cito is all right he's all right it was all
right I was real sad when he like came back
just to die but then it was like they got
the exposition the designs of the I think
they said Angel family yeah they were great
I recognized two of them the dad and the youngest
son looked really familiar oh yeah the guy
plays Rico's fine um I don't know I've never
read a Judge Dredd comic has this it's got
the energy it's got that like there's a lot
of that heavy overbearing like this is very
quotable it feels like it's in caps it's got
a lot of those like block off frame like so
it must be somewhat intense
like you know what I mean like I doubt Salon
read the comics so I I hope the director went
like this is Hardcore 90s whereas like I don't
know if Stallone was like I don't know if
they're making fun of it because they've read
okay yeah yeah because they they start off
with the comments they clearly someone loved
them and as someone who hasn't read the comics
I'm like maybe this is like the comics I don't
know where maybe is that what they're going
for this is like an undervalued film for an
adaptation I just I mean I hear the new one's
amazing
is incredible right so I mean that we'll see
what what we will compare those two and know
what the level of satire it is yeah because
that's that's but I think that left this left
such a bad taste to people's mouth that no
one can't remember that's the problem dread
loves it because yeah like Carl was out as
much of a household name and and like I remember
the posters for it and I'm like this looks
like this was supposed to look like I don't
watch it really Sylvester Stallone one but
I would love to see a sequel of this I would
love to see it it feels like a sequel yeah
that was the problem with it was that like
like I've I've heard that when you're making
a TV show one of the great ways to get your
one of the great ways to do a TV show a cool
tip I've heard is not always the case um but
one of the greatest I've heard really make
sure you get to know your characters is like
write your pilot and then write your second
episode in your second episode should be your
pilot and I think like there's a way you can
mix and match that that way you really know
the character and yeah but here I'm like well
first off you remove them from being judged
dreads like a half hour 20 minutes and then
all this like crumble of the city and uh the
the the Anarchy of the hierarchy dissembling
I'm like well I don't really know this world
I'm like I get that there was an opening crawl
to tell me about Judges I don't really know
what this world is a voice over opening curl
does not replace the first movie yeah yeah
and it definitely felt like they were just
like get to it and the stakes of him being
banished I mean it takes of backspawn cedo's
character being banished and Dread being uh
framed and and like oh this would be the sequel
where like Dread is no longer the man of the
law he's done so much and now he's outside
the lawn and he's outside the city walls that's
a good sequel story and like almost everything
here would have been better for a sequel or
a longer movie with better scenes so that
way all these scenes could feel like wow we've
really built us some craziness or like yeah
the third Act of this would have been all
that those elements yeah but we had to get
there we'd never got there the build up with
the clones and what a cast of like 90s like
eight like hit like hard hitters and like
the guys that I don't recognize but are like
character actors from that era so clearly
they like put a lot into it but something
missed Diane Lane's attractive dying Lane
um oh my God 30 years is just gorgeous I mean
we all know Diane Lane is actually an incredible
actress yeah this is not her best form not
she's learning but can you really say that
about like Max valencito who is another legendary
actor you know uh so yeah yeah the this was
uh it's got some cheesy ass dialogue I laughed
a lot awful pacing at times um robot it was
awesome because when it wasn't it when it
was not like I thought the guy played Rico
did a good job but at the end of the day robot
was great well they clearly a highlight but
when when it when judge Dred when that's the
thing is like when Stallone was whatever you
think about Stallone he's got something about
his Charisma that whatever he's on screen
when he's on screen the movie's pretty entertaining
but when when he's not on screen and it's
like focusing on other characters it's kind
of boring yeah say something great yeah it
gets a little boring even when you're like
with Max von Sito who's a great actor yeah
like movies but in this world I'm gonna go
back to Stallone because like Stallone is
the world so it like really feels like you
need to get back to his Ridiculousness nor
does it feel like yeah like I hate to say
it but it doesn't feel like a Vin Diesel choice
for you like it's got to be about me you know
right it still felt like it was an ensemble
movie yeah so focus on other characters and
stuff it didn't feel like Sylvester Stallone
being selfish make sure every shot's meeting
yeah yeah uh so I had fun I will probably
not watch it again for a decade but I like
I could enjoyed I took 30 years for me to
get around to this but I want to see the SEC
I do want to accept it for the new one I do
want to see this too but was I feel like I
feel like if if the sequel's as good as people
are saying it is it will be even it feels
like it would be even more appreciative for
us because we just enjoyed that and yeah it's
gotta be like so much if if if if we just
hop right to there maybe not love it but the
joy we got from this elevating no my God yeah
I'm so excited yeah I give this movie like
a success I was thinking of three to five
because I read it yeah so the same if out
of ten I'd say like six three it like passes
but man is it close yeah same yeah um
well hopefully dread the new one is not us
going like how is this so long and yet short
but we're gonna check that out next uh that's
like a hard R yeah here it's been brutal I
think it's like one location or something
in terms of like you're in one location in
a building and Olivia thoroughly wide door
and Lena Headey I hear something oh yeah so
yeah we're in for some good times we're checking
that out next thank you very much for joining
us on Greg and koi watch action movies if
you want to watch the limitation man let us
know if you want us to watch something else
in the comments let us know because we enjoy
these action movie Journeys we will see you
very soon reject Nation much appreciated bye
[Music]
thank you